جاوزنا 70 يوم ولا تزال المقاومه
الفلسطينيه قادره على ضرب القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
للقتال تتركز في الشجاعيه مخيم جباليه اي
الشيخ رضوان وبيت لاهيه تعود الى الواجهه
من جديد بعد اعلان كتائب القسام بانها
ضربت قوات اسرائيليه متوغل في هذه المنطقه
في منطقه بيت لاهيه وتحديدا المنطقه
الغربيه تقريبا من منطقه بيت لاهي ولكن
الحديث الابرز يدور عن منطقه الشجاعيه
بطبيعه الحال وهي المنطقه الابرز ل القتال
التي تدور فيها معارك عنيفه مع توغر
القوات الاسرائيليه في مناطق متفرقه من
الشجاعيه ولكن في المقابل عن ضرب قوات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لقوات الاحتلال في
منطقه الشجاعيه بطريقه مباشره ومحدده كما
قالت الكتائب في اكثر من مناسبه وقالت
الكتائب بانها لا تزال تضرب القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
هذه المنطقه يوم امس الاول ولا تزال تقول
الكتابه بانها توقع اصابات واضحه ومحدده
في القوات الاسرائيليه في منطقه الشجاعيه
اذا ما ذهبنا الى الحدث الابرز اليوم ونحن
نتحدث عن منطقه جحر الديك في المنطقه
الجنوبيه او المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه
جنوبي مدينه غزه هذه جحر الديك التي يحدها
من الجهه الجنوبيه وادي غزه كما نشاهد على
الخريطه هذا هو وادي غزه الوادي الشهير من
الجهه الشرقيه يحدها الخط فاصل او السياج
الفاصل من الجهه الغربيه شارع صلاح الدين
ومن الجهه الشماليه شارع كارني نتساريم
كما نشاهد على الخريطه اذا نتحدث عن جحر
الديك منطقه زراعيه لا تتجاوز مساحتها
حوالي 6.5 م م مربع ولا يبلغ عدد سكانها
اكثر من 5000 الى 5500 نسمه اذا هي منطقه
زراعيه بدرجه اساسيه كما نشاهد اذا ما
قربنا الصوره اكثر فنحن نتحدث عن مناطق
فارغه بشكل شبه كامل وجحر الديك هي سله
غذاء قطاع غزه وبالتالي الاراضي اللي فيها
اراضي مفتوحه بعض التلال المرتفعات
البسيطه في جحر الديك لا تتجاوز من 80 الى
100 متر مرتفع عن سطح البحر والانسياب او
الانحدار ياتي من الجهه الشماليه نحو
الجهه الجنوبيه نحو منطقه وادي غزه في جحر
الديك نفذت كتائب القسام هذه العمليه التي
قالت عنها اليوم وهذه بالمناسبه ليست اول
مره تتعرض القوات الاسرائيليه مثل هذه
العمليات في جحر ديك عام 2014 تعرضت
القوات الاسرائيليه لكمين للمركبه وتم
تدمير عدد كبير من دبابات المركا وفق
اعلان كتائب القسام اليوم مع توغل القوات
الاسرائيليه بدايه هذه المعركه وبدايه
التوغل البري بدا من منطقه جحر الديك بشكل
اساسي من المنطقه الشرقيه نحو المنطقه
الغربيه تعود كتاب القسام اليوم لتضرب هذه
القوات من الخلف ان صح التعبير بعد ان
تمركزت هذه القوات في منطقه جحر الديك
ليكون هذا المقطع هو احد ابرز المقاطع
الفيديو المنتشره في هذه المعارك بقي ان
اشير سريعا الى المنطقه الج النوبيه من
قطاع غزه وتحديدا منطقه خان يونس تقول
كتاب القسام بانها تضرب القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
ئب القسام وحركه حماس وموجود يحيى السنوار
هناك بحسب ما تقول اسرائيل